us-backed forces in Syria marking an
important milestone in the fight against
Isis
US Central Command says the fighters
broke through a key defensive wall and
entered the old city of Raqqa
american-led coalition coalition
airstrikes blasted holes in two sections
of the wall allowing the fighters
through Holly Williams is in northern
Syria Holly good morning good morning
the u.s. sent troops here to Syria
specifically to help in the fight
against Isis but that's just one part of
this country's bloody civil war amongst
the olive groves of northern Syria
beside a deserted village that's been
pummeled by artillery lies one of the
strangest front lines in the world one
this area is under the control of these
us-backed fighters but if you look over
here about five hundred yards away
that is Syrian regime territory and they
are backed by Russia and Iran and then
if you look down here about a mile in
that direction
those are positions that belong to
Syrian rebels and they're backed by
Turkey and if you're confused don't
worry
because so many of the people who live
and fight here some of the globe's most
powerful militaries are vying for
influence in Syria
the local commander of the us-backed
forces Shia Guri told his foreign
influence has wreaked chaos on his
country Medora things could get even
more complicated he told us we might be
here for another 10 years for the u.s.
this conflict is already complicated it
says it's not here to fight the Syrian
regime but last month
down a regime fighter jet in the nearby
city of manbij their battle scarred and
dreary in six years of civil war it's
changed hands three times
Achmed is a falafel maker who supports
his entire family on just three dollars
a day we're so tired of war he told us
we feel like we're already dead how far
the US will go to support its Syrian
allies once Isis has been driven out is
an open question as is how long American
servicemembers will stay here in Syria
to deal with whatever it is that comes
next
for CBS this morning Holly Williams
Derek in northern Syria